[Music]
thank you
Philip K Dick's novel The Man in the
High Castle has a lot of references to
two other books folded within to not
just the background but also in very
important ways the plot of the novel
itself now one of these is the ejing the
Chinese book of changes used within the
Pacific States and the Rocky Mountain
States
by quite a few of the characters and
we've discussed that elsewhere another
one is a fictional book fictional both
in the sense that in the universe it is
supposed to be a work of fiction but
also fictional in another sense and that
this book doesn't exist anywhere
in our world where Philip K dick was
writing a man in the High Castle it is a
made-up book within a fictional Universe
which is discussing how that Universe
could be radically different
and so it's essentially an alternate
history novel within an alternate
history novel so we get a very
interesting meta level here and as we're
going to see there's a few references
where dick might be hinting at his own
authorship or making a side joke in this
case it is attributed to this guy who's
an actual character as we meet late in
the the story Hawthorne abenson and
what's really key about this book so in
a man in the High Castle the Axis powers
uh Nazi Germany Japan to a lesser extent
Italy have won World War II uh they
eventually conquer the United States
except for the rocky mountain states
which are pretty helpless between the
Nazi occupied area in the East and the
Pacific States of America in this case
it's a little bit closer to our our
timeline
in that the Axis powers are going to be
defeated actually the the USSR which
will fight with the Allies will also be
defeated and the main winners are
Britain and the United States of America
and in the end we're going to see that
they're going to be at each other's
throats as well so it's not quite our
own history although it's a little bit
closer to our own history in certain
respects but as we're also going to see
the ultimate
um let's call it at the time resolution
will be closer to the resolution in man
in the High Castle the world that is
developed there so there's four main
groups of people or individuals who are
going to be discussing this book besides
of course towards the end Juliana and
abenson which we're going to talk about
later because there's an important
wrinkle that comes up there that we
don't want to discuss right now we're
looking at what people make of this book
and what the book actually tells us so
in chapter 5 we have Windham Matson and
his
um you know side piece Rita he's
cheating on his wife with with her and
she notices a book on his shelf and says
hey did you ever read this book so
that's where we pick up
he says no I never read it my wife got
that she reads a lot and Rita says well
you should read it so he picks it up and
he and he says isn't that one of those
band in Boston books and she says banned
through the United States and in Europe
of course and he says well I've heard of
this Hawthorne abenson but actually he
had not all he could recall about the
book was what that it was very popular
right now another fad another Mass craze
and he says I don't have time to read
popular fiction I'm too busy with work
secretaries he thought acidly read that
junk at home alone in bed at night it
stimulates them instead of the real
thing and he says one of those love
stories and she says no no it's a story
about war
uh and uh
she goes on and as they're driving
through traffic she says abenson's
theory is that Roosevelt would have been
a terribly strong president as strong as
link and he showed it in the year he was
President all those measures he
introduced the book is fiction I mean
it's in novel form Roosevelt isn't
assassinated in Miami he goes on and is
re-elected in 1936 so he's president
until 1940 until during the war he's
still president when Germany attacks
England and France and Poland and he
sees all of that he makes America strong
Garner so we're talking about in in the
universe was a really awful president a
lot of what happened was his fault and
then instead of night in 1940 instead of
brick or a Democrat would have been
elected and so
she goes on and she says his theory is
instead of an isolationist like Bricker
in 1940 after Roosevelt Rexford tugwell
would have been president and so now
we've got an imaginary character because
we don't have tugwell in our world he
would have been very active in
continuing the Roosevelt ansi-nazi
policies so Germany would have been
afraid to come to Japan's help in 1941
they wouldn't have honored the treaty
and so Germany and Japan would have lost
the war and that he's very skeptical of
this as a you know businessman and man
of the world and he says
um it's not funny you know this wouldn't
have happened and he says well how would
this and she says it's in fiction form
naturally it's got a lot of fictional
Parts it's got to be entertaining or
people wouldn't read it but there's like
an entire plan about how the U.S Fleet
is not destroyed at Pearl Harbor and
then Japan is defeated afterwards and
interestingly
what we see uh Windham Matson doing each
time is saying oh no that's not going to
happen so he's skeptical about the
possibilities and
you know he talks about Rommel for
example
and he says no strategy on Earth could
have defeated Irwin Rommel no events
like this guy dreamed up this town in
Russia very heroically called Stalingrad
no holding action could have done any
more than delay the outcome it couldn't
have changed it listen I met Rama what a
man what dignity and bearing so I know
what I'm talking about so he's he's the
kind of person who can't see the world
as having turned out very differently
right and uh what what else we find out
about this quite interestingly Windom
Matson says that or actually it's not
Windham Manson it's it's a
um Rita and she says it's okay to talk
about this the Japs have let it be
circulated in the Pacific I read a lot
of them are reading it it's popular in
the home Islands it's stirred up a lot
of talk so within the Japanese occupied
Pacific States of America within the
co-prosperity sphere even in the home
Islands Japanese people and everybody
else who's in their their group
are okay with these matters being
discussed it's forbidden once you go
into the Nazi Reich
so the next thing we need to look at and
this spans several different chapters is
Joe uh who's actually going to turn out
to be uh something quite different than
he pretends to be and Juliana who will
figure that out talking about this book
and Joe is actually setting a kind of
trap in a way a trap through seduction
and so
[Music]
um
he's talking about the book
he says you know what somebody says this
man this very funny sit down I want you
to re I I want to read you suppose they
had won what would it be like we we
don't have to worry this man has done
all the thinking for us opening the book
Joe began turning Pages slowly the
British Empire would control all of
Europe all the Mediterranean know Italy
at all no Germany either Bobby's and
those funny little soldiers in tall for
hats and the King as far as the Volga
Julianna says well would that be so bad
and he says you read the book and she
says no but Frank and I my former
husband and I often talked about how it
would have been if the Allies had
actually won the war and Joe goes on and
he says do you know how it is that
England wins beats the axis and she
shakes her head
and Joe says he has Italy betray the
axis Italy goes over to the Allies joins
the Anglo-Saxons and opens up what he
calls the soft underbelly of Europe but
that's natural for him to think that we
all know the Cowardly Italian Army that
ran every time they saw the British
drinking vino so he's sort of you know
uh talking about his own his own uh
ostensible group in very bitter terms
and then he he uh goes on as well and
starts you know reading parts of the
book to her and this is going to get
taken up again
um
later on she'll be reading passages from
that but first we want to talk about
this idea of visiting abenson
so they're in the the Rocky Mountain
States and not that far away and they're
talking about the book again
and uh they're talking about abenson
he's an ex-service man he was in the U.S
Marine Corps in World War II wounded in
England by a Nazi Tiger tank a sergeant
it says he's practically got a fortress
he writes in guns all over the place and
it doesn't say so here but I heard
someone say he's almost sort of paranoid
charged barbed wire around the place and
it's set in the mountains hard to get to
so this is the High Castle right that's
being discussed that's his pet name for
this compound and so Joe says then they
won't get him he's on the lookout smart
and Julianna says I believe he's got a
lot of courage to write that book if the
axis had lost the war we'd be able to
say and write anything we wanted like we
used to we'd be one country and we'd
have a fair legal system the same one
for all of us and
um you know she says I don't understand
you Joe what do you believe what is it
you want you defend those monsters those
freaks who slaughtered the Jews and then
you and then and uh Joe says let me
finish this meal you fixed for me and
um you know she can tell there's
something going on something happening
something terrible is happening she
thought coming out of him and I seem to
be helping it and he's actually going to
go on to suggest that that's something
as we're going to see in chapter 10
right
he goes He they're talking again about
the uh
possible uh past and uh they're they're
present and he says
you you take to that grasshopper book so
much
I wonder do you suppose a man who writes
a bestseller an author like that abenson
do people write letters to him I bet
lots of people praise his book by
letters to maybe even visit all at once
she understood Joe it's only another 100
miles his eyes Shone he smiled at her
happy again no longer flushed her
troubled we could she said you drive so
good it'd be nothing to go on up there
would it
slowly Joe said well I doubt a famous
man lets visitors drop in probably so
many of them and she says why not try
Joe all he could do is send us away
please and so he says well you know
we'll have to get prepared new clothes
haircut all those sorts of things and
then we'll go and visit this guy now
this is actually laying a plot which
we're going to see discussed a little
bit later with with somebody else but
first we need to go back to chapter
seven and look at what is being
discussed there I do want to point out
one other thing though before we move on
about Joe so he in fact is going to say
that the new deal that's being presented
there which extends not just to the
United States but gets extended to the
rest of the world China for example is
actually taking what was great about uh
the fascist and Nazi approach and sort
of taking credit for it but then leaving
out the bad stuff like concentration
camps and the you know extermination and
all that and uh you know he's making
quite an interesting point there from
his his perspective as we'll find out
anyway back to chapter seven with
children
so he is at the home of the casoras this
very you know Elite young Progressive
Japanese couple that have been stationed
in the Pacific States of America and
they begin to talk about this this work
right so he says uh I see you're reading
the grasshopper lies heavy I hear it on
many lips but pressure of business
prevents my own attention and he he uh
looks at them and says a mystery excuse
my abysmal ignorance now here's where we
get something really interesting so Paul
says not a mystery on contrary
interesting form of fiction
possibly within genre of Science Fiction
and then Betty says oh no no science in
it nor not sudden future science fiction
deals with future in particular future
where science is Advanced over now book
fits neither premise
and then Paul says it deals with an
alternate present many known science
fiction novels of that sort to Robert he
explained pardon my insistence in this
but as my wife knows I was for a long
time a science fiction Enthusiast I
began that hobby early in my life I was
merely 12 it was during the early days
of the war and then Paul extends an
invitation to him which is really quite
you know momentous care to borrow
grasshopper Paul asked we will soon be
through no doubt within a day or so my
office being downtown not far from your
esteemed store I could happily drop it
off at lunchtime he was silent and then
possibly children thought due to a
signal from Betty continued you and I
Robert could eat lunch together on that
occasion and this is like a very big
thing right and then they start to get
into discussion about American cultural
forms and jazz music and then the
alternate his history that the book
describes
Betty after a moment said one in which
Germany and Japan lost the war and then
a little bit later Robert says I would
like to know what he supposes it would
be like in a world where Germany or in
Japan lost the war and Paul says very
complicated differences better to read
the book it would spoil it for you
possibly to hear and then Robert says I
have I have strong convictions on the
subject I have frequently thought it
over the world would be much worse so
isn't this interesting we have you know
uh Frank and Juliana have thought this
over Windham uh um uh you know Matson
doesn't want to think it over Rita
thinks it's kind of interesting uh
children has thought it over but he's
come to a different conclusion it's a
good thing that the Nazis and the
Japanese won the war not the Americans
and British in his view the Soviets
would have taken over the world in that
case right but it's very interesting to
see that this is discussed as science
fiction and there's a case being made
for alternate history falling within
science fiction isn't isn't it so then
we we can go on and there's another uh
very interesting discussion happening in
chapter eight and here it's not between
people it's just one person reading it
to himself the reichs council rice who
is got some tension with the SD people
and he's trying to read the book to
himself and he finds that he's moved by
the passage discussing the fall of
Berlin and the death of Adolf Hitler
and so you know it says his eyes fell on
a scene involving Hitler he found
himself unable to stop he began to read
the scene how to sequence the back of
his neck burning the trial of Hitler
after the close of the war Hitler in the
hands of the Allies good God also
goodbel's guring all the rest of them at
Munich and
um you know they go on he gets
interrupted a few more times and then
we read something very interesting rice
shut the book and sat for a time in
spite of himself he was upset
more pressure ought to have been put on
the Japanese to suppress this damn book
in fact it's obviously delivered on
their part they could have arrested this
whatever his name is abenson they have
plenty of power in the middle west what
upset him was this the death of Adolf
Hitler the defeat and destruction of
Hitler the party in Germany itself as
depicted in Robinson's book now notice
what he's going to say here
is it was all somehow grander more in
the old Spirit than the actual world the
world of German hegemony
so this really upsets him and he's
thinking is this just this man's writing
ability you know he's he's sort of like
herbals writing fiction look how he
plays on sentiments
um maybe and then he says maybe this
abenson is a Jew
writing in the last outpost of the
former plutocratic U.S publishing
industry once located in downtown New
York and supported by Jewish and
communist gold they're still at it he
thinks trying to poison us and he says
this judicious book right a Jewish book
itself
um maybe somebody should go and pay this
person a visit and take care of him
right we should send Commandos in and
interestingly going back to this the
world is grander in the book than it is
in real life of his time he decides to
himself you know I wish this was over
does it have to go on forever the war
ended years ago we thought it was
finished then you know I have my routine
duties I don't have time for any of
these hair brained Adventures sending
eins Commandos after abenson my hands
are full greeting German Sailors and
answering coded radiograms let somebody
higher up initiate a project of that
sort so he considers it and then he
decides not to do it meanwhile there is
actually a plot by the SD to go and kill
Robinson and we finish up in chapter 15
with one more interesting thing being
noted about the book
this is by Julianne
this is after she finds out that Joe is
dead and she's deciding to go and uh
visit the the Robinsons
she reads the book at 6 15 in the
evening she finished it
I wonder if Joe got to the end of it she
wondered there's so much more in it than
he understood what is it Robinson wanted
to say nothing about his make-believe
world am I the only one who knows I bet
I am nobody else really understands
grasshopper but me they just imagine
they do
now what exactly it is that she is
thinking that she knows more about the
book we'll get to that elsewhere but it
is important that there's sort of a
crack opening up it's not just an
alternate history there's something else
going on with this work and we see that
people can have so many different
reactions to it it is in some respects
you know a object of derision and
skepticism uh an object of hatred but
also an object of speculation and
perhaps even freedom and hope so very
important imaginary uh alternate history
novel within the scope of this great
alternate history novel by Philip K dick